The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OK, we're moving on.
No more linear algebra.
We're going to try solving
some more difficult problems--
of course, all those
problems will just
be turned into linear
algebra as we move on,
so your expertise now
with different techniques
from linear algebra is
going to come in handy.
The next section of
this course, we're
talking about systems
of nonlinear equations,
and we'll transition into
problems in optimization--
which, turns out, look a lot
like systems of nonlinear
equations, as well.
And we'll try to
leverage what we
learn in the next few lectures
to solve different optimization
problems.
Before going on, I
just want to recap.
All right, last time we
talked about singular value
decomposition-- which is like
an eigenvalue decomposition
for any matrix.
And associated with that
matrix are singular vectors,
left and right singular vectors.
And the singular
values of that matrix.
Your TA, Kristen, reminded
me that you can actually
define a condition number
for any matrix, as well.
The condition we
gave originally was
associated with solving
square systems of equations
that actually have a solution.
But there is a condition number
associated with any matrix,
and it's defined in terms
of its singular values.
So if you go back and look at
the definition of the two norm,
you try to think about the
condition number associated
with the two norm, you'll
see that the conditions
of any matrix maybe
can be defined
as the square root of the ratio
of the biggest and the smallest
singular values of that matrix.
So there's a condition number
associated with any matrix.
The condition
number as an entity
makes most sense
when we're thinking
about how we amplify errors--
numerical errors, solving
systems of equation zones.
It's most easily applied to
square systems that actually
have unique solutions,
but you can apply it
to any system of
equations you want.
And the singular
value decomposition
is one way to tap into that.
OK, the last thing we did
discussing linear algebra
was to talk about iterative
solutions, the systems
of linear equations.
And that's actually
our hook into solutions
to systems of
nonlinear equations.
It's going to turn out
that exact solutions are
hard to come by for anything
but linear systems of equations.
And so we're always
going to have
these iterative algorithms,
where we refine initial guesses
for solutions until we
converge to something
that's a solution to the
problem that we wanted before.
And one question
you should ask, when
you do these sorts of
iterations, is when do I stop?
I don't know the exact
solution to this problem.
I can't say I'm
close enough-- what
does close enough even mean?
So how do I decide to stop?
Do you have any
ideas or suggestions
for how you might do that?
You've done some of this already
in a homework assignment.
But what do you think?
How do you decide to stop?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
is one suggestion--
look at my current iteration,
and my next iteration,
ask how far apart are
these two numbers?
If they're
sufficiently far apart,
seems like I've got some more
steps to make before I converge
to my solution.
And if they're sufficiently
close together,
the steps I'm taking
are small enough
that I might be happy
accepting this solution
as a good approximation.
That's called the
step norm criteria--
I'll give you a formalization
of that later-- it's
called the step norm criteria.
How big are the steps
that I'm taking?
And are they sufficiently
small that I don't
care about any future steps?
Another suggestion?
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
absolute [INAUDIBLE]
when we did that for homework,
I tried to do it [INAUDIBLE],,
and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I will show you a definition
of the step norm criteria
that integrates both
relative and absolute error
into the definition.
And we'll see why, OK?
One problem may be--
what if the solution I'm
trying to converge to is 0?
How do you define the
relative error with respect
to the number 0?
There isn't one-- there is
only absolute error when
you're trying to converge to 0.
So you may want to
have some measure
of both absolute and
relative step size
in order to determine
whether you're converged.
Is that the only way
to do it, though?
Have any ideas, alternative
proposals for deciding
convergence?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the residual.
PROFESSOR: The residual.
OK, what's the residual?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good, OK, so we
asked, how good a solution--
we can ask how good a solution
is this value that we've
converged to by putting it
back into the original system
of equations, and asking, how
far out of balance are we?
I take my best guess for
solution x, and multiply it by
and A, and I subtract b--
we call that the residual.
And is the residual
sufficiently converged, or not?
If it's small
enough in magnitude,
then we would say,
OK, maybe we're
sufficiently close
to the solution.
If it's too big, then we
say, OK, let's iterate
some more until we get there.
That is called the
function norm criterion.
We're going to talk
about these in detail,
as applied to systems
of nonlinear equations.
But these same criteria apply
to all iterative processes.
Neither is preferred
over the other.
You don't know the
exact solution--
you have no way of measuring
how close or far away
you are from the exact solution.
So usually you use as
many tools as possible
to try to judge how good
your approximation is.
But you don't know for certain.
What do you do, when
that's the case?
We haven't really talked
about this in this class.
You have a problem, you
program it into a computer,
you get a solution.
Is at the end of the story?
We just stop?
You get a number back out,
and that's the answer?
How do you know you're right?
How do you know?
We talked about
numerical error--
every calculation has
a numerical error-- how
do you know you got
the right answer?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK,
yeah, this is true--
so you plug your solution
back into the equation,
you ask, how good a job
does it do satisfying that?
But maybe this
equation is relatively
insensitive to the
solution you provide.
Maybe many solutions
nearby look like they also
satisfy the equation,
but those solutions
are sufficiently far apart.
So how do you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so that
sort of physical reasoning
is a good one.
In your transfer
class, you'll talk
about doing
asymptotic expansions,
or asymptotic
solutions to problems.
Solve this complicated
problem in a limit
where it has some
analytical solution,
and figure how the
solution scales,
with respect to
different parameters.
So you can have an
analytical solution
that you compare against
your numerical solution
in certain limits.
You have experiments
that you've done.
Experiment-- that's the reality.
The computer is a fiction
that's trying to model reality,
so you can compare your
solution to experiments.
You could also solve the problem
a bunch of different ways,
and see if all these answers
converge in the same place.
So we're going to talk about
solving nonlinear equations--
we're going to need
different initial guesses
for our iterative methods.
We might try several
different initial guesses,
and see what solutions
we come up with.
Maybe we converge all
to the same solution,
or maybe this problem has
some weird sensitivity in it,
and we get lots of
different solutions
that aren't coordinated
with each other.
One of the duties
of someone who's
using numerical methods to
solve problems is to try
to validate their result--
by solving it multiple
times or multiple ways,
or comparing against
experiment, or against known
analytical results,
and certain limits
where the answer
should be exact.
But you can't just accept
what the computer tells you--
you have to validate it against
some sort of external solution
that you can compare with.
Sometimes it's hard to
come up with that solution,
but it's immensely important.
We know every calculation
can be an error.
And as we go on to more
complicated problems,
it's even more important
to validate things.
So, systems of
nonlinear equations--
so these are
problems of a type f
of x equals 0, where x is
some vector of unknowns,
and has dimension N.
And f is a function that
takes as input vectors
of dimension N,
and gives an output a
vector of dimension N.
It's a map from R N to
R N. But it's no longer
necessarily a linear map-- it
can be some nonlinear function
of all the elements of this x.
And the solution
to this equation,
the particular solution
of this equation, x--
for which f of x
equals 0-- are called
the roots of this
vector-valued function.
The linear equations, then, are
just represented in this form
as A x minus b, A x
minus b equals 0--
it's the same as
the linear equations
we were solving before.
So we're searching for the
roots of these functions.
Common chemical
engineering examples
include equations of
state, often nonlinear,
in terms of the variables
we're interested in.
Energy balances have
lots of non-linearities
introduced into them.
Mass balances with
nonlinear reactions.
Or reactions that
are non-isothermal,
so their kinetics are
sensitive to temperature,
and temperatures are
variable, we want to know.
These sorts of nonlinear
equations crop up all
over the place, and you want to
be able to solve them reliably.
Here's a simple, simple example.
The Van der Waals
equation of state-- here
I've written it in terms of
reduced pressure, temperature,
and molar volume.
Nonetheless, this is the Van
der Waals equation of state.
And somebody told you once
that if I plot pressure
versus molar volume for
different temperatures,
I may see that, at
a given pressure,
there could be just one root--
one possible molar volume
that satisfies the equation
of state.
Or there can be one, two,
three potential roots.
It turns out we don't know,
with nonlinear equations,
how many possible
solutions there are.
We knew, for linear
equations, I either
had zero, one, or an
infinite number of solutions.
But with nonlinear
equations, in general,
there's no way to predict them.
This problem can be
transformed into a polynomial,
and polynomials are one of the
few nonlinear equations where
we know how to bound the
possible number of solutions.
So we can transform
this nonlinear equation
to the form I showed
you before-- we just
move 8/3 T to the other
side of this equation.
We want to find the
roots of this equation.
So possibly, given pressure
and temperature-- pressure
and temperature-- find
all the molar volumes that
satisfy the equation of state.
This is actually
overly simplified
for a particular
physical problem,
of looking at vapor liquid
coexistence of the Van der
Waals fluid.
You can't specify pressure and
temperature independently--
the saturation pressure,
the coexistence pressure
depends on the temperature
as the Gibbs phase rule.
So actually, phase equilibria
is made up of three parts--
there's thermal equilibrium.
I'm going to add two
phases, a gas and a liquid,
and they have to have
the same temperature,
otherwise they're
not in equilibrium.
There's got to be mechanical
equilibrium of two
phases, the gas and the liquid.
They better have
the same pressure,
otherwise one is going
to be pushing harder
on the other one.
They'll be in motion--
that's not in equilibrium.
They've got to have the same
chemical potential-- they have
to be in chemical equilibrium.
So there can't be any net mass
flux from one phase to another,
otherwise, one phase
is going to grow
and the other is
going to shrink.
They're not in equilibrium
with each other.
So actually, the
problem of determining
vapor liquid coexistence,
in this Van der Waals fluid,
involves satisfying a number
of different equations, some
of which are nonlinear,
and are constrained
by the equation of state.
Given the temperature, there are
three unknowns-- the pressure,
and the more volumes of
the gas and the liquid.
And there are three nonlinear
equations we have to solve.
Two of those are the
equation of state,
in the gas and the liquid--
I'll show them to
you in a second--
and the other is this Maxwell
equal area construction,
which essentially says that the
chemical potential in the two
phases is equal.
This is one way of
representing that.
So we have to solve this
system of nonlinear equations
for the saturation
pressure, the molar
volume of the gas or vapor, and
the molar volume of the liquid.
And these are those equations.
Here's the equation
of state and the gas,
here's the equation of
state in the liquid,
and here's the Maxwell
equal area construction
at defined values of
P sat, V G and V L
that satisfy all
three equations.
There's not going to be an
analytical way to do this--
it has to be done numerically.
Here's a simplification
that I can make, though.
So I can take that
equal area construction,
and I can solve for P sat
in terms of V G and V L.
And so that reduces
the dimensionality
of these equations
from three to two.
And when it's two dimensional,
I can plot these things,
so that's helpful.
So let's plot f 1--
the equation of state in the gas
is a function of V G and V L.
Where that's equal to 0,
that's this black curve here.
Let's plot f 2--
the equation of
state in the liquid
as a function of V G and V
L, where that's equal to 0,
that's this blue curve here.
And the solutions are where
these curves intersect.
So we're seeking out the
specific points graphically
where these curves intersect.
First, this solution,
and that solution
aren't the solutions we're
interested in at all.
That would say that the
molar volume of the gas
and the liquid is the same--
that's not really
phase separation.
We want these heterogeneous
solutions out here.
So we need some methodology
that can reliably
take us to those solutions.
We'll see that
that methodology--
the most reliable methodology,
and one of the ones
that converges fastest
to the solutions--
is called the
Newton-Raphson method.
But even before we do
that, let's talk more
about the structure of systems
of nonlinear equations,
and what sort of
solutions we can expect.
Does this example makes
sense to everyone?
Have you thought about
this before, maybe?
Yeah.
So given a function, which
is a map from R N to R N,
find the special solution, x
star, such that f of x star
equals 0.
That's our task.
And there could be no solutions.
There can be one to
an infinite number
of locally unique
solutions, and there
can be an infinite
number of solutions.
A solution is to
be locally unique
if I can wrap that solution by
some ball of points, in which
there are no other solutions.
That ball can be very,
very small, but as long
as I can wrap that solution
in some ball of points,
which are not solutions, we
term that locally unique.
So consider the
simple function, one
which depends on two
variables-- x1 and x2,
and f 2, which depends
on x1 and x2, equals 0.
And I'm going to plot, in
the x1, x2 plane, were f 1
and f 2 are equal to 0,
so that these curves here.
And here, we have a
locally unique solution--
we see the curves cross
at exactly one point.
Here, you can see
these two curves
are tangent with each other.
They could be coincident
with each other,
over some finite distance.
In which case there's a
lot of solutions that live
on some locally tangent area.
Or they could just
touch in one point.
So they may be tangent,
and the solutions there
are not locally unique, or
they may touch at one point,
and the solutions are--
there's one solution, and
it's locally unique there.
The reason why we talk about
locally unique solutions is
it's going to be hard
for a numerical method
to find anything
that's not locally
unique in a reliable way.
Locally unique solutions,
numerical methods
can find very reliably.
But if they're not
locally unique?
My iterative method
could converge
to any one of these solutions
that lives on this line, any
of these tangent points.
And I'm going to have
a hard time predicting
which one it's going to go to.
That's a problem if you're
trying to solve something
reliably over and
over again-- if I
converge to one of these
solutions, or another solution,
or another solution,
the data that
comes out of that process isn't
going to be easy to interpret.
There's something called the
inverse function theorem, which
says if f of x
star is equal to 0,
and the determinant
of this matrix, J,
which we call the Jacobian,
evaluated at x star
is not equal to 0,
then x star necessarily
is a locally unique solution.
So it's the inverse
function theorem.
The Jacobian is a matrix of
the partial derivatives of f,
if an elements of
f, with respect
to different elements of x.
So the first row of the
Jacobian is the derivatives
of the first elements
of f, with respect
to all the elements of
x, and the other rows
proceed accordingly.
If the determinant
of this matrix,
evaluated at the solution,
is not equal to 0,
then this solution is
necessarily locally unique.
That's the inverse
function theorem.
The Jacobian describes
the rate of change
of this vector-valued
function with respect
to all of its
independent variables.
And you may find that,
for some solutions,
the determinant in the
Jacobian is equal to 0.
We can't really say
what's going on there--
the solution may
be locally unique,
it may not be locally unique.
I'm going to provide you
some examples in a second.
And most numerical
methods are only
going to find one of these local
unique solutions at a time.
If we have some
non-local solutions,
that'll cause us problems.
So we tend to want to work with
functions that have locally
unique solutions to begin with.
OK, here's an example.
Oh, you have your
notes, so you know
the formula for the Jacobian.
Compute the Jacobian
of this function.
So this function has a root
at x1 equals 0, x2 equals 0.
If you think
graphically about what
each of these little
functions represents,
you would agree that that
route is locally unique-- it's
just one point
where both elements
of this vector-valued
function are equal to 0.
Here's what the Jacobian
of this function should be.
If you take the derivative of
the first element with respect
to x1, and then x2,
take the derivative
of the second element with
respect to x1 and then x2--
at the solution, at the root of
this function, where x1 is 0,
and x2 is 0, the Jacobian
is a matrix of zeros.
Its determinant is 0.
But the solution
is locally unique.
The inverse function
theorem only
tells us about what happens
when the determinant's not
equal to 0.
If the determinant's
not 0, then we
have a locally unique solution.
Solution may be locally
unique, its determinant
may be equal to 0.
Does that makes sense?
You see how that plays out?
OK.
There's a physical
way to think about--
or a geometric way to think
about this inverse function
theorem.
So think about the
linear equation,
f of x is A x minus b.
You can show-- and you should
actually work through this--
that the Jacobian
of this function
is just the matrix A. It says
how the function changes,
with respect to
small changes in x.
Well, that's just A--
this is a linear function.
So the equation,
f of x equals 0,
has a locally unique
solution when the determinant
of the Jacobian-- which
is the determinant of A--
is not equal to 0.
But you already
knew that, right?
We already talked
through linear algebra.
And so you know when this
matrix A is singular,
then we can't invert
this system of equations
and find a unique solution
in the first place.
So the inverse function
theorem is nothing more
than an extension of what we
learned about when functions
are and aren't invertible.
Because a locally unique
solution when A is invertible.
In the neighborhood of f
of x, in the neighborhood
of a root of f of x, we can
often approximate the function
as being linear.
We can treat it as though it's
a system of linear equations,
very close to that root.
And then the things that we
learned from linear algebra
are inherited by these
linearized solutions.
So here's this set of curves
that I showed you before.
Near this root, let's zoom in--
let's zoom in.
These lines look
mostly straight.
It's like the place where
two planes intersect--
intersect this x1, x2 plane--
they each intersect at a line,
and the crossing of those
lines is the solution.
And it's locally unique.
Because these two planes
span different subspaces.
Here's the case
where we may have
non-locally unique [INAUDIBLE].
Zoom in on this root, and
very close to this root,
well, it's hard to tell.
Maybe these two planes are
coincident with each other,
and they intersect and
form the same line--
in which case they may
not be locally unique.
Maybe if I zoom in close enough,
I see, no, actually, they
have a slightly different
orientation with respect
to each other, and there is a
locally unique solution there.
It's difficult to tell here.
So these cases where the curves
cross are easy to determine.
These are the ones that
the inverse function
theorem tells us about.
These ones are a little
harder to work with.
So I mentioned that you can zoom
in, and look close to a root,
and approximate the
function is linear.
This is a process
called linearization.
You are in this
for 1-D functions--
f of x, at a point
x plus delta x,
is f of x plus its
derivative times delta x.
And this'll typically be valid
for reasonably well-behaved
functions-- this sort
of a linearization
is going to be valid
as delta x goes to 0.
So as long as I haven't
moved too far away
from the point to x, I can
approximate my function
in the neighborhood of x
using this linearization.
You know, turns
out the same thing
is true for nonlinear functions.
So f of x plus delta
x is f of x plus--
well, I need the derivatives of
my function with respect to x,
and those derivatives are
partial derivatives now,
because we're in higher
dimensional spaces.
That's the Jacobian
multiplied by this vector
of displacements, delta x.
And this will typically
be valid as long
as the length of this
delta x is not too big--
as long as I haven't moved
too far away from the point
I'm interested in, f of x,
this will be a reasonably good
approximation.
As long as our functions
are well-behaved.
There's an error that's incurred
in making these approximations.
And for a general function
that's well-behaved,
that error is going to be
ordered delta x squared--
and they're in the 1-D, or
the multi-dimensional case.
And this sort of
an expansion, it's
just part of a Taylor expansion
for each component of f of x.
So we take element I of f.
I want to know its
value at x plus delta x.
That's its value at x.
Plus the sum of partial
derivatives of that element,
with respect to each of the
elements of x, times delta x--
each of those delta x's.
Plus, there are
some high order term
in this Taylor expansion,
which is quadratic in delta x
instead.
There's a cubic term, and so on.
These quadratic terms are
what give rise to this order,
delta x squared error.
In higher dimensions,
we typically
don't worry about
these quadratic terms.
We're pretty satisfied
with linearization
of our system of equations.
Sometimes for 1-D
nonlinear functions,
you can take
advantage of knowing
what these quadratic terms
are to do some funny things.
But in many dimensions,
you usually don't use that.
Usually you just think about
linearizing the solution.
So if I know where the solution
is, if I know it's close,
if I can figure out points
that are close to the solution,
then I can linearize the
function in that neighborhood--
I can find the solution to the
linearized equation, instead.
That's going to be suitably
close to the exact solution.
Does that makes sense?
Nonlinear equations, like I
said, are solved iteratively.
Which means we make a map
in our algorithmic map
which takes some
value xy and generates
some new value x plus 1, which
is a better approximation
for the solution we're after.
And we designed the map
so that the root, x star,
is what's called a
fixed point of the map.
So if I put x star
in on this side,
I get x star in
on the other side.
By design, the root is a
fixed point of the map.
The map may converge,
or it may not converge,
but the root is a fixed point.
And we'll stop iterating
when the map is sufficiently
converged.
You guys came up with
two different criteria
for stopping.
One is called the
function norm criteria.
I look at how big
my function is--
I'm trying to find
the place where
the function is equal to 0.
So I look at how big,
in the norm space,
my function is for my
current best solution,
and ask if it's smaller
than some tolerance epsilon.
If it is, then I say,
well, my function
is sufficiently close to 0--
I'm happy with this solution.
The solution is close
enough to satisfying
the original equation that
I'll accept it, and I stop.
The other criteria, it's
called the step norm criteria.
I look at two successive
approximations
for the solution.
I take their
difference, and ask,
is the norm of that
difference smaller
than either some
absolute tolerance,
or some relative tolerance,
multiplied by the norm
of my current solution?
So suppose x is a large number,
that spacing between these x's
may be quite big, but the
relative spacing may actually
be quite small.
And if the relative
spacing is small enough,
you might say, well, this
is sufficiently converged.
And so that's where this
relative error, relative error
tolerance, comes into play
in the step norm criteria.
Suppose x is a small
number, close to 0 instead.
These steps may be very tiny--
these steps may be quite tiny.
They may satisfy this
relative criteria quite well,
but you may want to put
some absolute tolerance
on how far these steps are
before you stop instead.
Because these x's may be
small in and of themselves.
And so this one is
easy to satisfy,
but this one becomes harder.
So you usually
use both of these.
Sometimes you have
solutions that
are converging
toward small numbers,
and then the absolute error
tolerance becomes important.
Sometimes you have
solutions that
are converging
towards large numbers,
and so the relative error
tolerance becomes important.
Does that make sense?
Of course, you can't just use
this one, or just use that one.
You typically like
to use all of these.
Because they can fail.
And if the function
norm criterion fail--
here's an example
where I'm taking
some iterations, some
approximate solutions
that are headed towards the
actual root of this function.
And at some point, I
find that this solution
is within epsilon of 0.
And so I'd like to
accept this solution,
but graphically
it looks like it's
very far away from the root.
So this is a case
where the function
has a very shallow slope.
It's a very shallow slope,
and the functional criteria,
not so good, really.
I call this a solution, but it's
quite a ways away from star.
So sometimes it's going to
work, but sometimes it's
not going to work.
Here's the step norm
criteria-- here,
I have a function
nowhere near a root--
I have no idea where
I am on this function,
I don't know what value
this function has,
but my steps suddenly
got small enough
that they're smaller than
this absolute tolerance,
or they're smaller than the
relative error tolerance.
I might say, OK, let's stop.
I'm not taking very
large steps anymore,
this seems like a
good place to quit.
But actually, my
function just after this
didn't go to 0 at all, it curved
up and went the other way.
There's not even
a solution nearby.
So both of these
things can fail,
and we try to use
both of them instead
to evaluate whether we
have a reasonable solution
to our nonlinear
equation or not.
Make sense?
Are there any questions about
that before you I go on?
No.
OK.
We also talk oftentimes
about the rate
of convergence of the iterative
process that we're using.
We might say it converges
linearly, or quadratically.
And the rate of
convergence is always
assessed by looking
at the difference
between successive--
well, we look
at the ratio of differences
for successive approximation.
So here's the difference between
my best approximation, step
i plus 1 minus the
exact solution,
normed, divided by my best
approximation at step i,
minus the exact solution normed,
and raised to some power, q.
And as I go to very large
numbers of iterations, i--
this limit should
be i, I apologize.
I'll fix that in
the notes online,
but this limit should be i--
is i, the number of steps
gets very large.
This ratio should
converge to some constant.
And the ratio will
converge to a constant
when I choose the
right power of q here.
So when this limit exists,
and it doesn't go to 0,
we can identify what sort
of convergence we get.
So if q equals 1,
and C is smaller
than when we say that
convergence is linear,
what is that saying, really?
This top step here is
the absolute error,
an approximation i plus 1.
This bottom step here is the
absolute error in step i--
remember two is one
for linear convergence.
So the ratio of absolute errors,
as long as that's less than 1--
I'm converging, I'm moving
my way towards the solution.
And we say that rate is linear.
If C is 10 to the minus
1, then each iteration
will be one digit more
accurate than the previous one.
The absolute error will
be 10 times smaller
in the next iteration
versus the previous one.
That would be great--
usually C isn't that small.
If this power, for which
this limit exists, q,
is bigger than 1, we say the
convergence is super linear.
If q is 2, which
we'll see is something
that results from the
Newton-Raphson method,
then we say convergence
is quadratic.
What that means is the number of
accurate digits in my solution
will actually double
with each iteration.
Linear, which equals
10 to the minus 1,
I get one digit per iteration.
Quadratic, I double the number
of digits per iteration--
I have one digit
on one iteration,
I get two the next one,
and four the next one,
and eight the next one.
So quadratic convergence
is marvelous.
Linear convergence, that's OK.
That's about the minimum
you'd be willing to accept.
Quadratic convergence
is great, so we
aim for methods that try
to have these higher order
convergences.
So you really quickly get
highly accurate solutions.
You can go back and
look at your notes
and see that the
Jacobian method,
and the Gauss-Seidel method both
show linear convergence rates.
They're linear methods.
Does this make sense?
OK.
So I meant it mentioned
Newton-Raphson.
Hopefully, somebody
at some point
told you about the
Newton-Raphson method
for solving at least
one-dimensional, nonlinear
equations.
It goes like this, though.
You say, I guess my solution is
close to this green point here.
Let me linearize my
function at that point,
and find where that linear
approximation has a root--
which is this next green point.
And then repeat
that process here.
I find the linearization of
my function, this pink arrow.
I look for where that
linear function has a root,
and that's my next
best approximation.
And I repeat this
process over and over,
and it will reliably--
under certain circumstances--
converge to the root.
What does that look like,
in terms of the equations?
So I linearized
my function, so I
want to approximate
f of x at i plus 1,
in terms of f of x at
i-- so it's f of x at i,
plus the derivative, multiplied
by the difference between x
i plus 1 and x i.
And I say, find the place
where this approximation
is equal to 0,
and determine what
the next point that I'm going to
use to approximate my solution
is.
So I solve for x i plus
1, in terms of x i.
How big of a step do I take
from x i to x i plus 1?
It's this big, so the ratio of
the function to its derivative
at x i.
And the derivative does the job
of telling me which direction I
should step in.
Derivative gives
me directionality,
and this ratio here tells me
the magnitude of the step.
The magnitudes,
you know, they're
not very good oftentimes,
because these functions
that we're trying to
solve aren't very linear.
Usually they're
highly nonlinear.
What's really helpful is
getting the direction right.
You could go right, you could
go left-- only one of those ways
is getting you to the root.
Newton-Raphson has
this advantage--
it always points you
in the right direction.
OK?
Of course, you can do this in
any number of dimensions, not
just one dimension.
So you can approximate
your function
as linear-- f of x i plus
1 is approximately 0.
And then let's take
our linearized version
of the function, and let's
find where it's equal to 0.
Sometimes what's
done is to replace
this difference, x
i plus 1, minus x i,
with an unknown vector, d i--
which is the step size.
How big a step am I going to
take from x i to x i plus 1?
And so we solve this equation
for the displacement, d i.
Move f to the other
side, so you have
Jacobian times d i is minus f.
And solve-- d i is
Jacobian inverse times f.
It's just a system
of linear equations.
Now we know our step size.
So x i plus 1 is x i
plus b, or x i plus 1
is x i minus Jacobian
inverse times f.
The inverse of the Jacobian
plays the same role
is 1 over the derivative.
It's telling us what
direction to step in,
in this multi-dimensional space.
And this solution to
the system of equations
is giving us a magnitude of the
step that's good, not great,
but is taking us closer
and closer to the root.
So this is the
Newton-Raphson method
applied to the system
of nonlinear equations.
This is really the
way you want to solve
these sorts of problems.
It doesn't always work--
things can go wrong.
What sorts of things
go wrong here?
Can you guess?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, this is good.
So in the 1-D problem, sometimes
the Newton-Raphson method
can get stuck.
So it won't have good
necessarily global convergence
properties.
If you have a bad initial guess,
it might get stuck someplace,
and the iterates will converge.
That can be true.
What else can go wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good, so
if you're derivative
is 0, that's going
to be problematic.
What's the
multi-dimensional equivalent
of the derivative being 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
Singular Jacobian, right?
So if this is J, the Jacobian,
has some null space associated
with it, how am I
supposed to figure out
which direction to step in?
There's some arbitrariness
associated with the solution
of this system of equations.
So the derivative is 0 in the
1-D example, that's a problem.
That problem gets
a little fuzzier,
but it's still a
big problem when
we try to solve for the
step size, or the step--
the Newton-Raphson step.
They may not be able to do this.
You don't run into
this very often,
but you can, from time to time.
One place where this
is going to happen
is if we have a non-locally
unique solution.
When we have one of those,
we know the determinant
of the Jacobian at that
point is going to be 0.
If we're close to
those solutions,
well the determinant
of the Jacobian
is going to be close to 0--
you might expect that the system
of equations you have to solve
becomes ill-conditioned.
So even though there
may be an exact solution
for all the steps
leading up to that point,
the equations may
become ill-conditioned.
You may not be able to
reliably find those solutions
with your computer, either.
So then these steps
you take, well,
who knows where they're
going at that point.
It's going to be crazy.
There are ways of fixing
all these problems.
Let's do an example.
This is a geometry
example, but you
can write it is a system of
nonlinear equations, as well.
So we have two circles--
circle f 1, circle f
2 in the x1, x2 plane.
They satisfy-- these
are the locus of points,
that satisfy the equation f
1 of x 1 and x 2 equals 0--
this is the equation
for one circle,
and this is the equation
for the other circle.
And we want the
solution, we want
the roots of this
vector-valued function, f,
for vector-valued x.
And those are the intercepts
between these two circles.
You can do it using
Newton-Raphson,
so you're going to need
to know the Jacobian.
So compute the Jacobian
of this function.
This is practice--
maybe most of you
know how to compute a
Jacobian, but some people
haven't done it before.
So it's always good to
make sure you remember
that the first row
of the Jacobian
is the derivatives of
the first element of f.
And later rows are
later elements.
You don't want the
transpose of the Jacobian.
Then it won't work.
OK, so should look
something like this.
There's your Jacobian.
The Newton-Raphson
process tells us
how to take steps from one
approximation to the next.
The step is equal to minus the
Jacobian inverse evaluated,
and my best guess for
the solution multiplied
by the function-- evaluated at
my best guess of the solution.
You're never going to compute
Jacobian inverse explicitly--
that's just code for solve this
system of linear equations.
So use the slash operator
in MatLab, for example.
And here you go--
I had an initial guess for
the solution, iterate 0
at minus 1 and 3.
This is somewhere
outside the circles--
it's pretty far away
from the solutions.
But I do my Newton-Raphson
steps, I iterate on and on.
And after four
steps, you can see
that the step size
in absolute value
is order 10 to the minus 3.
The function norm is
order 10 to the minus 3,
as well-- and maybe
order 10 to the minus 2,
but it's getting down there.
These things are
decreasing pretty quickly.
And I move to a
point that you'll
see is pretty close
to the solution.
Here's some things you need
to know about Newton-Raphson,
you'll want to think carefully
about as we go forward.
So it possesses a local
convergence property.
I'm going to illustrate
that graphically for you.
So here, I didn't solve the
problem once, I solved it--
I don't know, 10,000 times.
And I chose different initial
points to start iterating with.
Here, minus 1, 3,
that was one point.
But I chose a whole
bunch of them.
And I asked, how
many iterations--
how many steps did my
Newton-Raphson method
have to take before
I got sufficiently
close to either this root
here, or this root there?
I don't remember what that
convergence criterion was--
it doesn't really matter,
but there was some 10
to the minus 3, or 10 to the
minus 5 or 10 to the minus 8,
the convergence
criterion that I made
sure the Newton-Raphson method
hit, in both the function norm
and step norm cases.
And then, if the color
on this map is blue--
the solution converged to
this star in the blue zone--
if the color's orange, the
solution converged to the star
in the orange zone.
And if the color is light, it
didn't take so many iterations
to converge.
And if the color gets darker,
it takes more and more
iterations to converge.
So that's the picture--
that's this map.
I solved it a bunch
of times, and then I
mapped out how
many iterations did
it take me to converge
to different solutions?
So you can see if I start
close to the solution,
the color is really light.
It doesn't take very many
iterations to get there.
And the further way I
move in this direction--
still doesn't seem like it
take so many iterations to get
there, either.
I need a good initial guess--
I want to be close to where
I think the solution is.
Because once I'm over here
somewhere, I do pretty well.
And the same is true
on the other side,
because this problem
is symmetric.
There's a line down the middle
here, and along this line,
the determinant of the
Jacobian is equal to 0.
So we talked about these points
with the Newton-Raphson method.
And if I pick initial
guesses sufficiently close
to this line, you can see the
color gets darker and darker.
The number of iterations
required to converge
the solution goes way up.
Now, the Newton-Raphson method
possesses a local convergence
property.
Which means, if a
locally unique solution,
there's always going
to be some neighborhood
around that solution for which
the determinant of the Jacobian
is not equal to 0.
And in that neighborhood,
I can guarantee
that this iterative process will
eventually reach the solution.
That's pretty good.
That's handy.
These iterates can
go anywhere-- how
do you know you're
getting to the solution?
Are you going to
waste your time,
or are you going to get there?
So that's this local
convergence property associated
with it, which is nice.
But it'll break down
as I get to places
where the determent of the
Jacobian is equal to 0.
so there could be a zone--
it's not in this one-- there
could be a zone, for example,
like a ring on which the
determinant of the Jacobian
sequence is 0.
And if I take a guess
inside that ring, who
knows where that solution
is going to go to.
Could be something
like Sam said,
where the iterative method just
bounces around inside that ring
and never converges.
But when I have roots
that are locally unique,
and I start with good
guesses close to those roots,
I can guarantee the
Newton-Raphson method
will converge.
I'll show you next time that
not only does it converge,
but it also converges
quadratically.
So you start sufficiently
close to the solution,
you get to double the
number of accurate digits
in each iteration.
You can see that happening here.
OK, so I have one accurate
digit, now I have two.
The next iteration I'll
have four, and so on.
The number of accurate
digits is going
to double at each iteration.
So that's going to
conclude for today.
Next time, we'll talk about
how to fix these problems
with the Newton-Raphson method.
So there are going
to be cases where
the convergence isn't ideal,
where we can improve things.
There are going
to be cases where
we don't want to
compute the Jacobian
or the Jacobian inverse.
And we can improve the method.
Thanks.